let's go next to justin from orange
county california
justin hi yes i can
hi david i was just wondering uh what
your thoughts were on joe biden's town
hall yesterday and saying that he wasn't
planning on canceling
the 50 000 in student debt yeah so i i
we we talked about this a little bit on
a live stream earlier this week
i i appreciated that he was just being
direct in his answer
biden never ran on canceling 50 000 in
student debt
he's not pretending like he's going to
and he just said i'm i'm not going to do
it now some of the
some of the reasoning he gave uh about
well we want to do k through 12 stuff or
this or that i mean you can walk and
chew gum at the same time if he was
determined to cancel 50k
and do k-12 funding and improvements i
think he would be able to do it so i
think that
some of the reasoning after the fact
wasn't wasn't great
but i i was refreshed as i said before
you know if trump were to be asked will
you do 50k
trump would say well you know we're
thinking about a lot of different things
but you've got to remember that college
has really become indoctrination and for
a lot of people they go to college they
come out and all of a sudden they
believe all these horrible things like
crying chuck and crazy nancy are good
people and we gotta vote for crazy
bernie
so i'm not so big on college necessarily
although i went to u pen and got the
best grades and you know i i did so
great at the top school and my kids went
there
but you know ten thousand twenty
thousand fifty thousand these are
numbers and we're looking at them very
strongly and
we'll come back to that in some period
of time like that would be trump's
answer
right biden said yeah no i'm not gonna
do the 50k
and that's direct it's consistent with
what he said all along he's not
bamboozling anybody
so i appreciated the directness the
honesty i wish his policy were a
different one
so you stand behind the cancellation
personally
i don't know about full cancellation i
have my doubts about full cancellation
of all student debt i do think that
um the the reason i'm more partial
to partial would be that
we have a situation where sure college
is optional
but increasingly with more and more jobs
requiring college
and the cost of college going up and up
and up
it's it's not totally clean to me just
to say
if you choose to go to college then you
should you know just that's it you've
chosen and you should be responsible for
the full debt
at the same time to say everybody
just gets a full cancellation of all
student debt
i'm not there so i'm for a partial
cancellation
and i've seen a number of different
plans that would structure it
in different ways i don't know exactly
whether i would put a dollar amount on
it or a percentage or how i would do it
okay that makes sense thank you david
all right my pleasure
a lot of meaty substantive
questions coming in today